♪ ♪
>> Greg: KNOW WHAT MAKES ME
SICK?
ALL THIS AMERICA FIRST FROM
DONALD TRUMP.
>> WHEN THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
SPENDS TAXPAYER MONEY COMMIT WE
COULD USE IT TO BUY AMERICAN
PRODUCTS IN SUPPORT AMERICAN
JOBS.
MY FIRST TERM ALONE WE WILL
INVEST $400 BILLION.
THE PRODUCTS AND MATERIALS OUR
COUNTRY NEEDS TO MODERNIZE OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE.
>> Greg: WAIT, WAIT, WAIT, DID
HE SAY USE IT TO BUY AMERICAN
PRODUCTS?
I WONDER WHERE HE GOT THAT IDEA?
>> IN MY ADMINISTRATION WHO
LIVED BY TWO SIMPLE RULES, BY
AMERICAN AND HIRE.
BY AMERICAN ANNA HIGHER
AMERICAN.
BY AMERICAN AND HIGHER AMERICAN.
>> I’VE BEEN SAYING BY AMERICAN
EVER SINCE I I HAD BEEN RUNNING
FOR OFFICE AND LONGER THAN THAT.
>> Greg: MAYBE THAT WASN’T A
BAD IDEA AFTER ALL MR. TRUMP.
ANOTHER NASTY MOMENT WHEN HE
TURNS OUT TO BE RIGHT ALL ALONG.
JUST WAIT UNTIL BIDEN ASKS FOR A
WALL.
THE REST OF US HAVE CAUGHT UP TO
TRUMP, FOR EXAMPLE, WE REALIZE
CHINA ENGAGING IN WAR AGAINST
AMERICANS AND IT’S NOT A COLD 1
FOOT A LAST BILL HOT WAR THAT
DESTROYS AN ECONOMY AND DISRUPTS
LIFE FOR THE WEAPON MORE AND THE
MESSY RETALIATION.
BUT I THOUGHT JOE WAS KNOWN FOR
STICKING TO HIS GUNS?
IT WAS JUST DAYS AGO HE WAS
BARELY ABLE TO SAY THIS.
>> THIS GUYS WHOLE IDEA OF
AMERICA COME AMERICA ON ITS OWN
HAS BEEN AMERICA ALONE.
WE ARE OUT THERE BY OURSELVES.
>> Greg: HOW CAN YOU NOT
REMEMBER THE SECOND WORD AND
AMERICA FIRST?
SORRY, JOE, CREATING A POLICY
THAT STRESSES BUYING AMERICAN
GOODS OVER NOT BUYING AMERICAN
GOODS IS ACTUALLY PUTTING
AMERICA FIRST.
BUT I GET IT.
HE’S GOT A LOT ON HIS MIND.
PLUS IT’S ALL COVERED WITH
BLOOD.
I MEAN, WHAT DOES LONNIE KNOW?
>> LONNIE KNOWS EVERY FIBER OF
MY BEING.
WE PROPOSE, I PROPOSE THAT IT
CAN BE DONE.
I THINK WE ARE IN A POSITION TO
REALLY MAKE IT HAPPEN.
AND MY TEAM AND YOUR TEAM ARE
ALREADY WORKING CLOSELY TOGETHER
TO LIGHT THE PATH FORWARD HERE.
CRITICAL LAWS LIKE THE PRO
ACTORS AND COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING.
POLITICS BY PREVAILING -- LOOK
MY YES, AND TAKING TOO MUCH TIME
TIME.
>> Greg: YES, YOU ARE.
I HAVE NO IDEA WHAT HE JUST
SAID.
LOVE OR HATE TRUMP, ACTUALLY
CONNECTS TO CODE DOTS OFTEN
LOUDLY BUT JOE’S WORDS ARE JUST
LIKE JOE, ALWAYS IN DANGER OF
WANDERING OFF INTO THE WOODS.
BUT MAYBE THAT IS THE STRATEGY.
YOU CAN’T CRITICIZE WHAT CAN’T
BE DECIPHERED SO TEXT JOE
1-888 -- I FORGOT THE REST.
WHERE’S MY SUIT?
SO JESSE, YOU ONCE SAID THAT WHY
SHOULD YOU VOTE FOR JOE BIDEN IF
JOE BIDEN IS GOING TO BE A TRUMP
LIGHT?
THIS IS AN EXAMPLE OF BEING HIM
TRUMP LIKE?
>> HE PLAGIARIZED BY BUY
AMERICAN, AND IT WOULDN’T BE THE
FIRST TIME HE PLAGIARIZED HIM
POLITICS.
BUT I DON’T CARE.
I THINK IT IS ACTUALLY GREAT
THAT BOTH CANDIDATES FROM BOTH
PARTIES HAVE A MORE ECONOMIC
NATIONALIST, POPULIST APPROACH
TO THE U.S. ECONOMY.
SO WITH BIDEN MOVE TO THE RIGHT
ON THIS, GO TO.
IT MOVES THE CONVERSATION IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION BECAUSE THIS IS
WHERE THE CONVERSATION IS GOING.
IT WILL BE A LESS COME A
MULTILATERAL WORLD.
WE WILL HAVE MORE KIND OF A
GUNBOAT MERCANTILISM IF YOU GUYS
KNOW WHAT I’M TALKING ABOUT
WHERE WE WILL PROTECT OUR OWN
SHIPPING WITH OUR OWN NAVY AND
NOT PROTECT THE ENTIRE WORD
WORLDS FREE TRADE WITH THE NAVY
PIER THOSE DAYS ARE OVER.
THE COLD WAR IS CRUMBLING AND WE
ARE GETTING BACK TO AMERICAN
FIRST.
TRUMP IS RIGHT.
JOE IS GOING FAR LEFT ON THE
ENVIRONMENT, AND HE’S GONE FAR
LEFT ON THE POLICE.
I HONESTLY DON’T KNOW WHERE JOE
IS AT ANY GIVEN MOMENT, AND
NEITHER DOES HE.
>> Greg: LORENZO, IT DROPS THE
MERCANTILE IN RESPONSE.
JUAN WE HAVE TWO REPUBLICANS
RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT.
>> Juan: YOU CAN’T SAY THAT
THAT’S THE LEFT POINT BUT HERE
IS MY TAKE ON THIS.
PRESIDENT TRUMP’S RATINGS ARE
PRETTY LOW AND HAVE GONE DOWN.
BUT THE ONE AREA IN WHICH HE
STILL POLLS WELL AND GETS THE
APPROVAL OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
IS THE ABILITY TO HANDLE
ECONOMIC ISSUES.
THEY SEE HIM AS SOMEONE THAT CAN
DO THAT.
I THINK JOE BIDEN AND HIS
CAMPAIGN OR SPEAKING TO THAT
STRENGTH RIGHT NOW AND SAGGING,
LET’S LOOK AT MANUFACTURING.
LET’S LOOK AT MINING.
LET’S LOOK AT SOME OF THE ISSUES
LIKE FARMING.
HAS THAT GOTTEN BETTER?
HAS PRESIDENT TRUMP LIVED UP TO
ALL THE PROMISES HE MADE ABOUT
REVIVING THOSE ECONOMIC SECTORS
AND SAYING NO.
AND IF YOU WOULD LIKE JOE BIDEN,
JOE BIDEN SAYS, HE, IN FACT WILL
MAKE ON THOSE FAILED PROMISES
THAT CAME FROM DONALD TRUMP.
THAT IS THE BIG DIFFERENCE TO
OFFER A POSITIVE VISION.
AND I THINK IT MAY BUILD BACK
BETTER.
AND I THINK, HEY, I CAN DELIVER
ON THE ECONOMY WHERE THE
INCUMBENT IS NOT DOING IT.
IT IS A POSITIVE AGENDA, AND I
THINK, YOU KNOW, YOU THINK BACK
TO THE TAX CUTS AND THE WHOLE
THING LED TO THE BUYBACKS FOR
THE BIG CORPORATIONS THAT ENRICH
THE VERY RICH IN OUR COUNTRY.
DIDN’T BRING BACK WAGES OR JOBS
AND I THINK HE IS SAYING THAT IS
A FAILED ECONOMIC PACKAGE AND
HERE IS AN OPPORTUNITY TO
ACTUALLY BRING TO LIFE WITH THE
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAVE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT.
SO IT’S NOT PLAGIARISM.
IT’S SAYING, LET’S DO IT AND GET
IT DONE.
>> Greg: YOU KNOW, DANA, WHO
KNEW JOE BIDEN IS A WHITE
NATIONALIST?
>> Dana: THINK ABOUT WHERE HE
GAVE HIS SPEECH TODAY,
PENNSYLVANIA.
PENNSYLVANIA WILL BE THE MAIN
BATTLEGROUND STATE, I THINK
COMING UP IN THIS 3.5 MONTHS ON
ELECTION DAY.
SO JOE BIDEN HAS SOME WORK TO
DO, ESPECIALLY IN THE COUNTIES
OR HE WAS TODAY.
I UNDERSTAND THAT VOTER
REGISTRATION FOR DEMOCRATS IS
DOWN 20%.
SO IF HE WANTS TO TRY TO FIND
VOTERS WHO WENT FROM OBAMA TO
TRUMP, AND HE WANTS TO GET THEM
BACK TO HIS CORNER, HE HAS WORK
TO DO.
THAT IS ONE OF THE REASONS YOU
SAW HIM GO OUT THERE AND DO THIS
TODAY.
THE OTHER THING, BERNIE SANDERS
INVITED THE WORKING STAFF AND
WORKING COMMITTEES TO TRY TO
FIGURE OUT WHERE MIGHT THEY BE
ABLE TO AGREE.
INSTEAD OF MOVING TO THE CENTER
HAS GENERAL ELECTION CANDIDATES
USUALLY DO, JOE BIDEN CONTINUES
TO MOVE MORE TO THE LEFT.
MAYBE NOT ON THE ECONOMIC ISSUE
IN PARTICULAR, BUT I THINK THAT
BERNIE SANDERS WOULD BE VERY
COMFORTABLE WITH BUY AMERICAN,
HIGHER AMERICAN, THAT IS HIS
WHOLE WORLD.
THE OTHER THING IS THAT BIDEN
COME AS SOON AS THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN STARTS TO FOCUS ON
PUSHING HIM TO WHERE HE IS AND
SAYING HE SO FAR LEFT, AND HE
WILL GO FURTHER LEFT, HE LIKES
WHAT BERNIE LIKES.
HE WANTS TO GIVE HEALTH CARE TO
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS.
HE’S GOING TO DO THE GREEN NEW
DEAL ALL THE WAY.
WE WILL ELIMINATE JOBS IN
PENNSYLVANIA.
JUST RELENTLESSLY FOCUSING ON
HOW BIDEN WILL ACTUALLY BE
BEHOLDEN TO THE LEFT SEEMS TO ME
TO BE WHERE THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN
SHOULD TRY TO FOCUS ON THE NEXT
FEW WEEKS.
>> Greg: WHAT DID YOU THINK,
KENNEDY?
>> Kennedy: I’M NOT A BIG FAN
OF POPULISM ON EITHER SIDE, BUT
IT IS ESPECIALLY DANGEROUS WHEN
IT COMES TO THE LEFT BECAUSE IT
BREEDS AUTHORITARIANISM.
AND THE ECONOMY IS REALLY GOING
TO GO DOWN.
WHAT THEY ARE GOING TO DO IS
HAVE THESE FEDERAL MANDATES ON
WHAT YOU CAN BUY AND WHO YOU CAN
BUY IT FROM.
IT’S NOT JUST A SENSE OF
GOODWILL THAT I WANT TO HELP OUT
MANUFACTURERS AND WORKERS AND
WORKERS WHO HAVE GREAT IDEAS AND
BUY THEIR PRODUCTS AND SERVICES.
IT IS GOING TO BE DONE BY FORCE.
SO WHEN YOU INCREASE SPENDING,
THEY WILL ALSO INCREASE TAXES.
THERE IS NO GREATER CERTAIN WAY
TO TANK THE ECONOMY THAN TO
MARRY THOSE TWO DEVILS.
THAT IS WHAT JOE BIDEN IS DOING
WITH US.
WHEN WORKING IN CONCERT WITH
BERNIE SANDERS, WHO IS ABOUT A
SOCIALIST COMMIT IS HORRIBLE
NEWS FOR THE ECONOMY.
AND I THINK AS HE MOVES UP IN
THE POLLS, THE WORST IT WILL BE
FOR THE MARKET.
AND THEY WILL REALLY START
REACTING TO THAT.
ALSO, DANA CAN TELL YOU THIS, IT
IS ALWAYS A GOOD IDEA TO STEAL
WHATEVER IS WORKING FROM YOUR
OPPONENT.
IF THE PRESIDENT WERE TO STEAL
SOMETHING FROM JOE BIDEN COMEAUX
WHAT IS HIS PHRASE OR HIS IDEAS?
THE FOUNDATION OF IDEOLOGY THAT
IS SO POPULIST AND WORKING SO
WELL THAT THE PRESIDENT WOULD